so Darren I I have to share what we just
heard as we're sitting in the back of
the theater a Khadem II member s on her
way out said I salute you and I leave
you which i think is kind of high praise
right that's you she's having a reaction
she's she's feeling a strong reaction to
what it is that you've made it's that
part of what you were driven by to
actually kind of elicit reaction I mean
yeah a little bit I mean we always knew
it was a strong cocktail it came very
much from a place of a lot of
frustration and I guess a certain amount
of as already calls it impotent rage on
what was going on in the world and I
just I just kind of took all that
passion that I was thinking of outside
of my filmmaking work and tried to turn
it into a story I won't ask about your
creative process when you have this idea
for a film and you write it very quickly
you take it to your partners at protozoa
and what does the creative process look
like what is the initial conversation
that you have with your producers and
what are the steps on this film that
maybe unlike others that you've made
before well normally we spend a lot of
we've spent a really long time sculpting
the scripts this one I was very
interested in I was kind of inspired by
songwriters who can write a take a
single emotion and kind of write
something that is very effective for a
whole generation of people and I just
had this idea of what happens if I
follow a single emotion and can you make
a film out of that and so I wrote this
without telling them which was weird
because I usually include them in
everything but I just was like it was
more of an experiment to see what came
out and then when I showed it to Scott
and Ari they were you know they were
they both had very very you know intense
reactions to it said there's something
here and then we just started to explore
what it would be to do it we really made
the film very differently it was a whole
different process there was a lot more I
wouldn't say it was improvisation but
there was a lot more of like building as
we went along
and so that was through the
production design for sure and the
cinematography and then definitely with
the sound design when the score suddenly
didn't make sense anymore for the movie
and we had to rely but it was and it was
a long 53 week long post you know mostly
because there's only three shots in the
film there's only we're only over her
shoulder on her face or her POV so
there's no coverage in the entire movie
to go back to an edit room without a
wide shot is not you know not fun for
your editor not fun for the editor so
every single moment Jennifer had to be
working mhm and that's like the
accomplishment for me the film is like
you never kind of lose track with her
you may like not quite understand what
she's experiencing but you're she's
keeping you safe and keeping you
cocooned and that's reinforced by all of
the different departments that we have
up here so it's got you and re have
strong reactions to what he's brought
you how do you what does the
conversation go from there and what does
the rehearsal process do in terms of
satisfying the questions and concerns
that you have as producers I mean my
first reaction was you know knowing
Darren's work both obviously in film and
what he's passionate about outside of
film my first reaction was to how
powerful it was and felt it was really
important film to make and something I
felt passionate that we'd have to make
right away so you know you know we
support I supported that already
supported that and I can't speak to the
rehearsals we had three months of
rehearsals which is something that we've
never done before certainly and I think
is unusual and that was really an
opportunity to a number of things we
taped out the whole house laid the first
floor in yellow in a and in the second
floor in green in a warehouse in
Brooklyn we went through the entire
script with the actors and so that
became a period of time where the actors
brought a lot to taking these all these
ideas that were in the script of which
there were very many and then really
grounding them in character and making
the relationship feel very real and so
that process really cemented a lot for
the film you also make a very
fundamental and important casting
decision very
early on and that is casting the house
and the way in which this house is gonna
become a character in the story you talk
about your conversations with a
production designer about what this
house had to be what the references were
and how you came about building it I
think it started with location scouting
and the first we were like oh maybe
we'll find a house in a field that's a
metaphor for the planet earth or in
Brooklyn all right which would have been
great well we did look in Brooklyn for a
while - the one nice thing that came out
of the scouting is we stumbled on an
octagon-shaped house which was a style
of Victorian home that was a big deal
talk a little bit about that out of
science behind it so we we saw this
octagon house and we were sort of struck
by how just how strange the shape was
and there was something it was a house
but it was also sort of a little bit
more than a house we looked inside and
saw that the rooms because it was fit
inside an octagon and all had kind of
strange shapes to them and then we dug a
little deeper and saw that the idea of
the octagon house and Victorian
architecture was based on one of the
people that was performant of it was
phrenologist and it was guy that was
mapping the human brain via the shapes
of people's skulls and his idea was that
the octagon house was sort of the most
pleasing shape for the brain and that
was enough for us we're like well that's
cool we're doing a haunted house so
Matthew your director says there could
be three shots over the shoulder point
of view our close-up of Jennifer and
you're shooting in an octagon house and
you're gonna shoot 16-millimeter go is
that basically the instructions well I
mean I expect a certain box when I work
with Darren and every single time we one
of the things that we've always done is
crate rules for ourselves and we both
come a long way and how to deal with
those rules and how to manipulate them
when we talk about the rehearsals one of
the things we did was shoot those
rehearsals we shot the entire film with
a 5d and just worked out through work
the scenes out and that gave you know
some of the camera crew an opportunity
to understand how limited the language
was it gave us an opportunity but it
gave the actors an opportunity to know
they had what space and what box they
had to work in but what I you know I
think what we took away from that is
that we learned after we cut that
together where you know where we
actually did have to cut you know I mean
we did a lot of moves in rehearsal that
were wonders but then you know we were
we ended up rotating the camera around
so much and then knowing full well we
were gonna go to an octagonal house
moving in a circle it was just we had to
start to be a little more strategic and
in having not no coverage at all we
could we use blocking - you know her POV
could be a wide shot of three people or
it could be it over the shoulder or a
tight shot of somebody depending on
where she stopped so we started to get a
little more clever with the blocking so
all that came from rehearsing really
Gregor when I asked you about the sound
design about how important it was to try
to get natural sounds where you got
sounds for the heartbeat in the wall
there's some amazing things that
happened during the childbirth sequence
what was the rule in terms of what you
could invent and what you could find in
nature and manipulate the basic rule
with Darren is natural sounds trying to
find natural sounds organic sounds and
manipulating them in such a way as
different ways to sort of bend or more
for pitch or reverse whatever it takes
but nothing synthetic so everything was
sort of based and sort of a real thing
so the heartbeat for instance just
discussions with Darren and I about
mammals and large animals and stuff and
we sort of hit upon elephant whales and
sort of 25 BPM 16 BPM 42 BPM and this
was really early on in the process but
the idea was sort of you know could we
somehow map a heartbeat for the house
not just visually but internally so when
when Jennifer's character is going the
art that she takes can it somehow build
and slow and build and slow just sort of
dramatically that didn't really we
didn't really actually follow that all
the way through but what we did hit upon
was a really interesting sort of
rhythmical beat for the heartbeat in the
wall and so I was able to sort of
manipulate that in a way that initially
you see it it's kind of opaque and you
don't really see what it quite is and
then it slowly gets a little bit more
the next time you see it's a little bit
more visually there and then the cancer
sort of starts coming on in and the
blackness sorta comes on it so it's
another layer of like you know rock and
it's starting to harden and stuff so
that was sort of the the idea was taking
sort of natural and real sounds elephant
wails sort of ideas but not ripping off
an elephant wails sound but actually
taking the rhythm of it and then trying
to basically make sounds up that would
match that sort of thing so therefore we
had flexibility and how we wanted to
sort of manipulate it was it important
and I guess you can't control timing but
the fact that this movie's coming out
right after two devastating hurricanes
does that make what you were writing
about a couple of years ago feel even
more topical I mean it's depressing as
all hell
I mean I outside of this I'm on the
board of directors of the Sierra Club
and so I'm reading everything that's
going on and two years ago when I was
writing this it was incredibly
heartbreaking I talked about you know my
grandparents came to this country to
give me a better life and I look at my
son and I'm scared and I think that fear
is what inspired me to kind of tell a
story from a heart point of view because
it's a story we don't really think about
it it's very hard to understand you know
the large but while those two storms are
going on they're also the largest forest
fire in the history of Canada is burning
in British Columbia you don't think
about that but you do think about when
someone comes over your house and burns
a hole in your carpet with their
cigarette and you never forget that
person you know
so I thought maybe taking this boot
taking this boon well idea right
taking the boon well idea of like
putting a dinner party and a surreal
concept of them stuck in a room and
discussing all of society with that one
idea that hey this might be there might
be a way to use that to take something
really big and make it small and then
make it more impactful for people thank
you so much Darren guys thank you